With the advent of refrigerators, we can
Preserve our foods for a longer period than ever before.
But is there a difference between fresh and frozen foods?
What should we address?
You may shout "Of course fresh food is better, it's fresh". By instinct.
May be right. But that depends heavily on the circumstances.
In many cases, the food you take may be from the shelf in the shop
It was harvested before reaching maturity to avoid damage during travel.
This means that it has not yet reached its food peak.
Furthermore, food content begins to deteriorate in the minute in which food is collected,
Then the food is loaded onto a truck, boat or plane, traveling for several days and then waiting on the shelf for you to choose.
After that, these foods may remain in your refrigerator for a few more days before they are eaten.
During this period of up to weeks, foods may lose up to 50% of their nutritional value.
On the other hand frozen foods are selected when they are ripe and frozen immediately.
While rapid freezing affects the content of vitamins,
They basically freeze or lock most nutrients in place.
In addition to fresh products that have remained for weeks,
There is no doubt that frozen foods can contain a greater nutritional value,
Especially during the month, which is not a season for local products are transported from long distances.
In a series of studies, after 3 days of storage, frozen broccoli had the highest or highest level of vitamin C and beta-carotene.
While frozen berries were much higher in containing polyphenols and anthocyanins,
Frozen buds recorded the highest percentage in all dietary measures.
Of course if you pick fresh vegetables from your garden or get them from the local farmers market,
The same day, it can not be compared to frozen foods in terms of nutritional value and taste.
But if you are not able to shop every few days, frozen products are a great alternative to you.
Did you like our own whiteboard, looking to free your creative side?
Check out our friends at Absecs who have created stunning and adjustable blackboard desks,
Which we now use with pride.
Write down the funniest when they attack you, or just make random drawings or scribbles on your desk.
If you have watched our video about sitting, you know how important it is to stand from time to time.
These things are really fantastic, they offer our viewers a $ 50 discount on any size and model for the iPad.
Check with UpDesk.com and use the UPDESKASAP promo code, and subscribe to the channel for more science per week. "Translation: team autrjim @"